come on it's time for another chapter of  my Rags to Riches life story  [Music]  welcome to Acapulco  hello everyone get to work  memo was finally working at the pool  with me  Chad and Julia made their engagement  official but I was happy for them  because I had my eyes on someone new  maximum  [Music]  so what's maximo's deal  I think he's Mexican  [Music]  history I don't know do I  anyway  a dark time in my life was approaching  is  my family was at risk of losing  everything  but sometimes things have to break apart  to come back stronger not us  [Music]  there's a room  life doesn't always take you where you  think you should go  has a way of leading you to  [Music]  YouTube  [Music]  happiness is about finding where you  belong  [Music]  the owner of the whitest ass in Mexico  please come to the front desk  who's messing with the PA  hey not funny  [Music]